- Okay Angela, this is you.
(button dinging)
(audience laughing)
- [Angela] What?
(bell rings)
- [Kelly] Oh.
- [Angela] Oh.
People who don't show up-
- [Kelly] And they say.
- or just in general,
do what they say they're going to do.
- Oh, they don't do,
when they don't do what they
say they're going to do.
- Right, right.
You say, "Oh, I'm gonna be there for you.
"Oh, I got your back.
"I'll pick you up at the airport at 2:43."
And now it's 4:30, you know? (laughs)
So-
- Yeah.
- People, if you say
you're gonna be somewhere,
you say you're gonna do something, do it.
- See this.
- Be a man or woman
of your word.
(audience applaud)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That's what I like.
- And see, I am a woman in my word,
which is why I don't commit a lot.
- Same.
- I don't commit a lot.
- Same, same.
- I'm like, you know what?
I could be there, but I might not.
(audience laughing)
- Let me see-
- I know.
- 'til I can be definitive.
- If I say a hundred
percent I'm going be there,
I'm gonna be there.
- Then, I'm gonna be there.
- But usually, I leave myself a back door.
(audience laughs)
(Angela laughs)
Yeah, 'cause it's just,
you just don't know.
I'm a single mom of two kids.
I got a lot of jobs, just a lot, so-
- Yeah, well tell me up
front, tell me up front.
You can't be there, 'cause if I say,
"Kelly, can you pick me up?"
Easy out.
- Oh, no, no.
I would, I would.
- "Can you pick me up?"
Easy out.
'Cause, I'll give you the easy out.
- Do you know what I say?
- What?
- Even in my family, judge me.
I don't care.
(Angela and audience laugh)
- When my family comes visit, I'm like,
"Woo! I'm gonna have a car for you there.
"They're gonna pick you up."
Because usually I'm at home with my kids.
And it's like, I never have an off day,
so I'm like tired.
But like, most people
are like, "That's rude.
"You can't, like, go pick your family?"
And I'm like, "No!"
- No.
- "'Cause I'm paying for
a driver to go do it,"
and that's kind.
(audience clapping)
Like, it's not kind, people, you can clap.
A lot of people aren't clapping.
(Angela laughs)
- I don't care.
In life, I know they're not clapping.
- 'Cause it's love.
Love picks you up from the airport.
- I know, I know.
- Love makes that airport run.
- Maybe it does, but my kind of love.
- Nothing says love
like, "I'll pick you up."
- I know, see we're from the south.
That's what people from-
- Or like nothing says love
like, "I'll help you move." (laughs)
- But I'll tell them, see,
there again, I'm like,
"I won't, but I'll pay someone too."
(both laugh)
(audience laugh)
- That's a kind love.
I feel like that's a kind of love.
Look, I'm working so hard
that I have the ability to
pay someone to help you.
(Kelly laughs)
Like, I have helped people
move, but I'm grown.
I'm tired.
(Angela chuckles)
I don't wanna do it.
(audience laugh)
- Yeah, that's right.
- I don't wanna do it.
So, but you know what I don't do?
I don't tell people I'm going
to, and then I don't do it.
- [Angela] That's everything.
- Yeah.
- That's all I'm asking.
- Okay, my last one.
(button thuds and dings)
So far, people think I'm
a horrible human. (laughs)
(audience laugh)
(bell rings)
- Oh no.
- [Angela] Cold showers?
- Dude.
The amount of cold showers
I've had to take in my life.
Like, pipes burst, I live in
a house, it's like hundred, I-
- Oh, It nothing worse.
It's like, over a hundred years old.
It's like, I don't know
how many cold showers
I've taken in this house.
But it's not kind, it's not cool.
- Don't take hot water for granted.
- No, and when you're on tour,
you have to go in these venues,
and it's like, I go in
apparently after every person
on the planet has showered.
(audience laugh)
And there's no more hot water.
- But you know-
- And it's a freezing shower.
- what I've just read, you know,
it helps your cellular health.
If you have to take a shower,
a two minute cold shower every day,
if you want to live to a hundred.
It's one of the few things you can do,
to not just outward looking good,
"You look good for your age."
- But inward looking good
and living a long life.
- That's incredible.
- 'Cause it shock,
it shocks it, you know?
- [Kelly] No, that's
incredible, I've heard that too.
- That, intermittent fasting-
- I'm okay with living to 80.
I'd rather just, like,
live to 80.
- Okay, well I hate it that.
But have you done this?
There's this thing called, where you go,
it's like a meat locker and you go in.
- Oh, the cryo thing?
- Yeah, cryotherapy, and
it's 30 something degrees.
Have you done that?
- No, but what's funny-
- Is that better
because water is not involved?
- No. I've never seen, but
Ariana showed me a video,
we're working on "The Voice" together,
and I was like, "She literally,"
I was like, "Are you?"
It looks like torture.
She showed me this video and I was like,
"Hell no, I'm not gonna do that!"
- I've done it like once or twice.
- [Kelly] Have you?
- And it's great.
They have, it's so cold,
they have to put booties on your feet.
And on your fingers, so
then you know, frostbite.
- Oh my God!
- And then you have a robe,
you take it off, put
on your favorite song.
I think I put on some Beyonce.
- Yeah.
♪ Ah ka-ka ka-ka ♪
- You gotta feel powerful.
- And you're just,
for three minutes, for three minutes.
- [Kelly] I can do that.
- You're just in there.
And it is truly mind over matter.
- [Kelly] I could do three minutes.
- I flew out of there.
Like, "I am so cold!"
- Yeah, she looked terrified.
I was like, "Oh my God,
"you look like you're being tortured."
- I know, but I'm living to a hundred.
- [Kelly] Okay, you probably will.
- One day, one time.
- You know what?
(Angela and audience laugh)
I don't mind not living to a hundred.
(both laugh)
I'm like, "Ah, a good 80
years would be great."
No, I would do the ice thing.
- [Angela] No, no.
- You know the thing,
that they get in the ice?
- That athletes do.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The ice bath.
- I would do that, but I
think I'm just challenged,
like how long can I stay in it, you know?
It's like a game.
- I'll need some hypnotherapy
or something, before that.
- Oh man, no, I think I can do it.
I'm gonna do it.
- You could,
but not a cold shower?
- I, no, but here's the thing,
that's, like I'm getting
ready for work, my day.
I don't wanna be pissed off.
I don't wanna be mad, yeah.
(Angela and audience laugh)
And I'm getting ready
for my moment, my day.
I don't want a cold shower then.
That's not kind, no.